another late-breaking item both starting
tackles for the kansas city chiefs eric
fisher
and mitchell schwartz placed today on
the covet 19 reserve list we don't know
if they tested positive or whether they
were in close contact with someone who
did
either way peter you start doing the
math and
you quickly get to the conclusion that
the chiefs are going to be in the same
spot the raiders were in several weeks
ago
although the raiders were missing their
entire starting offensive line during
the practice
week the chiefs are going to be down
their two starting tackles
until saturday and they play sunday
night
look you know this is one of those
things that i think mike at the
beginning of the year we thought
that if patrick mahomes let's say for
instance had a
large part of his uh
uh of his front wall decimated for a
week or two and they couldn't play
because of covid
that the nfl might say well this is one
of those things that
we might want to postpone a game and we
might want to create a week 18
so that we made sure that we are not
putting
patrick mahomes in harm's way but
they've sort of now made drawn the line
and
drawn the line in the sand and said no
this is what the practice squad is for
and if you have to play two or more
replacement players even in front of the
most valuable player
contractually anyway in all of football
you better get those guys ready and you
better be able to play
so mike i don't think that first of all
you're going to see clark hunter andy
reed or brett veach
calling the league office and say hey
cut us a break here
put this in week 18. i think you're
going to say the cheat you see the
chiefs saying
okay next man up and let's go yeah peter
i think you're right
at some point about halfway through the
season so far and i think it was that
raiders buccaneers game where the
attitude became
screw it we're getting these games in
we're going forward
you don't have your vetoes too bad get
ready
yeah yeah guy just walked in the door
today and he's got to play tonight
that's on you
you don't have enough guys on the
practice squad to fill in for the guys
who are gone
that's not our problem we are getting
these games in because i think as you've
said before if they would bump it
a couple of days to accommodate the
chiefs and give them a chance to get
fischer and schwartz ready to go there's
no guarantee it's going to be any better
because of the incubation period because
of that doughnut hole in the
sample collection and sample result
you've got to kick the ball when it's on
the tee because you never know when that
virus known as lucy is going to snatch
it away from you and screw
things up so sunday night game on
too bad if you're down your entire
offensive line and patrick mahomes the
most important player
in the league is left to fend for
himself we're getting this game in
mike uh you know a lot of people are
going to look at that and say this is
idiotic
uh it's it's it's a huge mistake
you know there's a reason why you've
made it possible to have a week 18
use it and i think my attitude is look
it's very early in the week you just
don't know
if he loses if they lost their entire
offensive line including backup players
i think then you're going to have to
really ask yourself the question
should they play this game and my answer
would be no absolutely they shouldn't
but a lot of people have asked in recent
weeks
why not just use this why not push it
back and again i know we've talked about
this but
i think it's really important to realize
that you know
the nfl in the middle of march
with free agency three or four days away
basically when the pandemic really hit
the united states
the nfl said hey full speed ahead we're
going ahead with free agency
and the reason why because there was no
guarantee it wasn't going to get any
better
and it didn't get any better exact same
thing happened with the draft did it get
any better no
not for a couple of months after that
and so
i think they're going to do the exact
same thing here
i think the one place and it's only the
one place
where i wouldn't be surprised if there
was some time taken
is the super bowl because once you get
down to one
final game uh if there is a significant
outbreak on one side or the other
i think they might say okay we're
putting these two teams in a bubble
uh in two separate bubbles and we're
gonna do that and then we'll play the
game in two weeks
but before that even if there is a
bubble in the playoffs mike
i doubt sincerely that unless there is a
real widespread outbreak
that they're going to be postponing many
games and the reality at this point
peter and you had a quote from an
unnamed league official in football
morning in america
today there's a sense of beat the clock
when it comes to the pandemic the
numbers are going up dramatically
in all the communities where the nfl has
teams and everywhere else
in the country get the games in
get the games in that's the attitude
they don't want to postpone anything
because we don't know that there even
will be a week 18 or a week 17. it could
be that they ultimately have to pull the
plug after x number of games
so get every game in before we get to
the point where
the house of cards potentially would
collapse on the nfl so i think that's a
big part of it too
there's an urgency to get every game
played regardless of any strategic
realities that could impact one team or
the other
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports